Who will win this year? After all, the
candidates will be Deus or Orovas tomorrow.
Irma got 0 points.
I couldn't find it either
Later I found out how it works, but that's a prank by the organizer It's
safe
to say that it's impossible to harvest
.
There is no such
thing
as a guess.
Iruma-kun is certainly unexpected
, so bring a bouquet of legendary leaves
to the chairman
[Music]
Congrats on winning
late  I'm sorry
for being so [music] I can't afford it right now, but I really
want to give it to you
The flower language of sunflowers makes me
happy
[music]
[Applause]
I wanted to see that smiling face of the possible Amelie So
I guess that's already a
proposal